c
so
for
we know that
jean sme all seem sincerely
seniors called back on monday it's just
after
yes
his release
i had
ap
and it's still known
m
this
that's that it's not secure all his
future matches
that  alone to be customers and
particularly that
discreet game
his martyrdom at 50
who themselves as official
he
this day
this dedication
you all have
how the pc game
[Music]
people to quote it
missed
[Music]
oh
the  choose
[Music]
you
bombay the side
e
the cinema
[Music]
saved we feel it
targeted and that they can take care
[Music]
in the name of the father of the son and the
holy spirit peace be with you
come  dear brother and sister we were
there in this cathedral to celebrate the
dedication of this cathedral of course he would go
force nobody the whole chapter
of course they were there the faithful
so many as usual today
it is with many  of emotion that we
are here  i am celebrating the
dedication of this cathedral but we
are deeply happy to be able to
celebrate the eucharist there what
it was built for
it is also a message of hope and
thanks to all those who
were moved by what  arrived at this
cathedral a sign of our france but
also a sign of its
Christian roots many testimonies it
would take too long for me to list them
here from all over the world very
simple things children who drew me
drawings who wrote poems  and
it is to them that I am also addressing this
tic crisis which is going to be celebrated to
show that here is the cathedral is
still alive since the Eucharist is still celebrated there
thank you to all of you for having agreed to
come here you chaplains vicars
general those who are used here
become of course all those who
work on the reconstruction of this
cathedral those who are responsible for it
told me the extraordinary enthusiasm e  t
that he rediscovers the spirit that had
this cathedral built in the past, all
these workers who inspire and
participate in a common work, this
is a bit like what is happening today
between the companions, all those who
work here for the security
of  first of the cathedral and then to
consider its rehabilitation
here we are here because we
know that here in this cathedral
it is the sign of a presence this
presence will join us during
this caristy to welcome it and  to
open our hearts to this
present first together we all wait for
his mercy recognizing that we
are from a bhl sinners
i confess a place from where mighty i
will raise that i have fished in arab thought
pass
that is why  i smile the stone of the
husband the stakes that is healthy and you
also true to tie current of the lord
may almighty god have
mercy may he forgive us our
sins lead us to eternal life
kirill e  t they are there
[Music]
his game
oh yes
[Music]
my body
no
d
[Music]
it's my style
we were there
my tickets
I
all
[Music]
yes molise
becaud yes
yes they would know in particular
sushi decathlon
[Music]
m
we were all born here my file
slips you this
[Music]
wow
first name bleeds it
on the day our cathedral church
was consecrated under the name of the
Blessed Virgin  mary
listen lord the prayer of your faithful
give wolf by his intercession to
constitute a healthy people whose worship
of great glory by jesus christ your
son our lord is our god
tivity rule with you in the unity of the
holy spirit now and for the
centuries of centuries
reading of the apocalypse of saint john
me I saw a lens that said to me
come on I will show you the woman the bride
of the lamb in the spirit took him on a
big and high mountain
he took me  showed the holy city jerusalem
which came down from heaven from near god
she had within her the glory of god her
brilliance was that of a very
precious stone like jasper and crystalline
she had a great and high wall
with twelve gates and on her gates
twelve angels names were  inscribed
those of the twelve tribes of the sons of israel
there were three gates in lorient 3
honor 3 in the south and three in the west the
wall of the city rests on 12
foundation bearing the names of the twelve
apostles of the lamb word of the lord
the inhabitants of your house
teach friends at home
my soul is exhausted in longing for the courts of the
lord my heart and my dear are
crying out to the living god
[Music]
m
loison himself has found a home
and  the swallow a nest to shelter its
brood tea hotels lord of the universe
my choice and my god
e
[Music]
the inhabitants of tam and we know
happy the inhabitants of your house
they will be able to sing to you win god
see our shield look at the face  of
your but if it takes me in yes a day
in your pavia is worth more than a thousand
i have chosen to stand on the threshold
in the house of my god
[Music]
the English referees cross on stage
aldi fog
reading of  the first letter of saint
peter apostle fresh approach the
lord jesus
he is the living stone rejected by
men but chosen and precious before
god you too as a living stone
enter into the construction of the
spiritual abode to become the
healthy priesthood and present
spiritual sacrifices pleasing to god by
Jesus Christ indeed there are these
in the writing
I will lay in Zion a
cornerstone a precious chosen stone
whoever puts his faith in it would not
know shame
so therefore honor to you believers
but for those who disbelieve it
is written the stone that the builders were rejected
has become the
cornerstone a stumbling block a rock to
stumble upon
i  the stumbling block those who refuse to obey
the word
and this is what was to happen to them
but you have chosen yourselves a descendant
a royal priesthood a
holy nation a people destined for salvation so
that you announce the wonders of
him who has given you  called from darkness into
his wonderful light word of the lord
hallelujah hallelujah hallelujah
go
to
and
behold the dwelling place of god with men
they will be these peoples and he himself god
with the will be their due
[Music]
to
the lord be with you  jesus christ
alone 11 saint jean
[Music]
at that time celebrating the feast of the
dedication of the temple in jerusalem
it was winter
jesus came and went in the
temple under the colonnade of solomon the
jews formed a circle around  him and
told him how long are you going to keep us
in suspense
if it is you the dilemma crisis is
openly
Jesus answered them I wanted to say and
you do not believe the works that
I am doing in the name of my father
vo  this is what bears witness to me but
you do not believe yourself because you
are not one of my sheep my sheep
listen to my voice
I know them and they follow me I
give them eternal life
they will never perish and no one
will snatch them  from my hand my father who
gave them to me is greater than anything and
no one can archers from the hand
of the father the father and I are one we
acclaim the word of god
[Music]
this is today we are celebrating  the
dedication of this cathedral in this
cathedral
what a joy for us the word dedications
you may know comes from
dedications thing which means
consecration it means that the
dedication is the consecration of a
church to divine worship what we
celebrate  by the dedication each year
it is the deep reason for which
the cathedral notre dame was built
quite simply to manifest the moors
the man towards god
the cathedral was born from the faith of our
ancestors they manifest their  confidence
in the goodness of christ his love
stronger than hate his life stronger
than death is also this very
special tenderness of Christians towards the
virgin mary
this mother whom the lord gave us
as his last testament
this mother whom he gave us  gave so
that we take care of her in the same
way that she takes care of us that's
why this cathedral was
dedicated to her our lady notre dame de paris
it was her most precious possession which
she gave to us before she died on  the
cross
this cathedral was also born of
Christian hope
this hope perceives well
beyond a small personal life centered on
oneself to enter into a
magnificent project at the service of all and by
projecting itself well beyond a single
generation as  we see it
today those who work on the
construction site tell me their enthusiasm
we find, as I said at the
beginning, this spirit of communion that
there was in a beautiful work that
surpass each of those who
build it what a marvel it
is not a question of leaving a name it is a question
of building something for the
service of all these
are the ones who manifest hope
well beyond a generation or a
given time
it is the future that is always being built
it was also born from charity since
this cathedral is open to everyone
and it is always open to everyone
except at the moment for security reasons
you have
paid for it  it is the refuge of the poor and
the excluded who found their
protection there
this case naturally recalls the words of
quasimodo asylum asylum and it is true that
everyone could take refuge in
this cathedral and I hope that it will
always be true  moreover, the hôtel dieu
which was built right next to it has
always been associated with the cathedral which
was this sign of this
unconditional welcome for the poor and the
sick and I hope that we will be able to
rediscover this spirit of those who
have  ruit this cathedral
because they are the poor the sick
the excluded who have the first place
in the church as the lord has
taught us
now the question that arises for
us is do we have high faith in
our ancestors
are we ashamed of christ today
yes this cathedral is a place of
worship it is its own and unique purpose
there are no tourists another drama
as i hear it sometimes this term
is often taken from  in a pejorative way
because in fact everything that comes here
does not come in like tourists
by saying that we are not doing justice to this
mystery which pushes humanity to come and
seek something beyond itself and all the
chaplains who are here around me
can testify that many
entered as it may be out of
curiosity without really knowing why
but did not come out in the same
way because there is a
presence a presence perhaps
implicit but undeniable
that is what was important  of rapping  ler
in relation to this cathedral
because can we really by ignorance or
by ideology separate culture and
worship
the etymology itself shows us the
strong link that exists between the two and
I say it with force a culture without
worship becomes an inculture
it is indisputable since already everything
that is cultural and artistic has
always been done in function and
because of ten minutes is superior
or of transcendence
and if I speak of a culture it is
only to be seen  the abyssal religious ignorance
of our contemporaries due to
the exclusion of the divine notion and the very
name of god in the public sphere
in the name of a secularism which
excludes any visible spiritual dimension
like any building this
cathedral includes a stone  cornerstone
this cornerstone carries the
whole building and for us this
cornerstone is indeed that of christ if we
removed this stone this cathedral
would really collapse it would be a
rooster  uille empties a case without jewels a
lifeless skeleton a body without soul
this cathedral is indeed the fruit
of human genius it is the masterpiece
of man but the human person is
the fruit of divine genius it is
the masterpiece of god we
heard it when christ said that no
one can snatch someone from his hand
that means that the
human person every human person is
known to god and that gives him a
character of  an immeasurable unsurpassable dignity
is the ch is the work of god
seems to us it is the work of god
last sunday i was with ten thousand
young teenagers and he had offered me
something precisely to remember
what s  went to our lady
he gave me a lectionary the same
lectionary I had given to the
firefighters
only this one was new it was
not a little burnt like the one I
gave to remember what happened  passed
that day and well I reminded them
that my real cathedral  rale were they
these 10000 stone which was there and which
builds the church of today
but this building recalls precisely that
these precious stones need a
place which is as precious as it and
that is why this cathedral was
edified but precisely when the
human genius joins the divine genius
when the two come together in the
person of jesus christ true god and
true man then
the alliance is truly accomplished between the
transcendent elimane years between heaven
and earth
it is here  and now in this
cathedral at each of our accary ch'ti
celebrated that this covenant is realized
when the flesh of Christ shared by
all opens us to eternal life
may this mass celebrated on this
particular occasion but followed
by millions of people seem-  can he
give back this taste to the baptized to return to
seek there the very source of their
existence here below and not only
in a
future life eternal life begins today?  ui and
precisely it begins with each of our
eyes caristie lé renews because it is the
lord himself who gives himself in
food our dads for an earthly life to
supply food to the
organic and biological body not but to
supply the food of  the soul that
allows us to be in contact with god,
this is the extraordinary meaning and it
was well worth building a cathedral
and it is certainly worth rebuilding
it is an understatement of course that we are
happy to celebrate this mass to
give back to  god what belongs to god
and man his sublime calling
amen
oh
[Music]
vivi
il
et d
[Music]
theo
promised
[Music]
oh
way too personal
i shoot
[Music]
m
at bedtime j  I promised
[Music]
what are we missing foods
leave you b to c is a hydra
symantec offers for us it's over
[Music]
weepu not very high level there to be
like magnificent ode to queen au  day
cough and the video we build marinelli
if we like t 90c
[Music]
oh
e
[Music]
this
let's pray together mom to make the
sacrifice of the whole church as
we remember before you Lord the
day you made our
cathedral church the place of your glory and  his
holiness we ask you to
transform us into an offering that
will be pleasing to you not jesus the christ
our lord to the lord with the
monsignor center
[Music]
truly it is right and good to make
the world offer you our
thanksgiving  to don josé antonio highly
bleed very holy father eternal and
almighty god because you want to invite to
spread been well done the house of
prayer that our fathers have built upright that
never ceases to amplify the church that you
face and this church is  the true
house of prayer which prefigures our
churches here below it is the temple or
of a black murtagh the abode of
the immortal to avoid the sanctuary
of eternal love this church it marries
unique and beloved as christ
conquered the price of his blood and who makes him
live by his spirit he is a beautiful our
mother because we are generated
again by your grace we of life from
you strengthen him by the thread surrounded
by the care of your mercy  this is
why with the angels and all the
saints
our fields mow we proclaim
[Music]
saint-seine lord god
the
call to the Beninese
[Music]
to the highest
must we really be there without you who is
the source of his whole head and here we are
gathered before you and in the
communion of the whole church we
celebrate the anniversary of the dedication
of this church
on this day when you consecrated it is filled
with your presence by Christ the Lord  and
leader of your church god our father we
pray that it becomes for us the
body and blood of jesus our lord
sum who made his offerings by spreading
on your spirit that it becomes for
us the body and blood of jesus
christ our
lord  time to be delivered and to enter
freely into his passion he took the
bread he gave thanks he broke it
and thence to his disciples in ten years take
and eat in all this is my body
delivered for you
[Music
] likewise  at the end of the meal and the prices the
cup again he gave thanks and
gave it to his disciples by weaving kone and
drink in all because this is the cup of
my meaning the meaning of the eternal new covenant
which will be poured out for you and
for the multitude in remission of
sins does this to you in memory of me
[Music]
it is where the mystery of faith
we take as we saw ourselves the water rising
direction
[Music
] here remembering death and
resurrection of your son
we offer you Lord the bread of
life and the cup of salvation and we
give you thanks because you have chosen us to
serve in your presence
humbly we ask you that
by having by the body and blood of christ
we are gathered by the holy spirit into
one body
[Music]
I
under the skin according to joël flew away
like staying on all fronts
[Music]
oh
on 120 tried cm
with his mother
m
so
moutier we are not wandering there
he is the champion of France destroyed
this your son
[Music  ]
sponsored trouble
and two
the rhdp without naming metellus ap
total downtime must for
centuries of centuries
[Music]
oh
united were to this country we can say
with confidence learned yesterday that
we received from our savior
our father who is eyes  that we receive
without blinking that time to listen
today
we also speak those who
preceded us and do not let enter into
temptation but free the books us from
all evil lord and in peace in
our time by your mercy nor bern
or sin reassure us in the face of
trials in this life where we hope for
the happiness you promise and the advent
of jesus christ our savior because it is
yours lord jesus christ you said to
your apostles I leave you peace  x I
give you my pay do not look at our
sins but the faith of your church so
that your will his accomplice in him
always this peace and leads there towards
perfect unity you who reign for
centuries of centuries that the peace of the
lord  always be with you
[Music]
by the charity of christ give you
peace
certainly
at t3 10 beijing saturday noon
adios day i quit with spices p4 money in
[music]
news territory
bk modi dona nobis missed
[music]
guest at the lord's meal
here is the lamb of god who takes away the
sin of the world
lord jesus dead to mehdi only
word of the body of christ keep us
for the vine and m
the scene
[Music]
everyone vibrates be leaped towards you
I cry the night the day that  show us
be in support
a friend told me you we fall back to 1
wasyl in the world
[Music]
a new day the most beautiful
I knew it could be for you I said
[Music]
he will come day  get out of my game
d-day and of the world be my  support
oh you let us get up let's
laugh together you wanted lord that
your church on earth be for
us announce it from celestial jerusalem to
strings no by this communion to be here
below the temple of your grace and to enter  one
day near the holy virgin mary in
the dwelling of your glory by jesus the
christ our lord
my lord that you know it
many christians of the east saw their
churches their cathedral destroyed by
acts of war or by terrorism
and yet they were  deeply
touched by what happened to our
lady of paris
they sent us many
testimonies of friendship and desolation
the maronite christians of aleppo in
particular in the cathedral was
somewhat in the same state as our lady of
paris have  wanted to sculpt this stone
in a stone from the vault of the
cathedral of ales they sculpted this
stone and they asked the work
of the orient that I direct to want to
put it back so that it is of a
certain  e way
placed in our lady restored as a sign of
this spiritual link with the Christians
of the East with the Maronite Christians
of Aleppo their bishop Monsignor Tobji and
all the people
so I thank you very much
my Lord thank you thank you very much
here it is a sign  very beautiful that our
Eastern Christian brothers who have
suffered a lot as you know
not only in their churches but
also in their flesh wanted to mark
this communion we have been close
to them all the time they were
victims of this terrorism  and of this
war and today it is them who
show us their friendship their sympathy
their fraternity dieter although we
are in communion I will
of course have the opportunity to meet them it is
already wars but thank you really to
them i think if sometimes they
watch by kto i know some
can watch it by kto
i really tell them with all my heart
thank you thank you and staying in communion
because we  know that christ
this cornerstone that makes us
live text
flush
from hell will not prevail over
the church of our lord jesus christ
and this cross is truly the only one
will of course find its place
in our lady restore thank you very much
dear father  vers 6 1
now it is the moment of the
blessing this blessing of course
extends to all those who are here all
those who know the cathedral that
they love it who have been touched who
may be watching us also that this
blessing  extend far beyond the
walls of this cathedral the lord
be with you without bless you
the father
the son and the holy spirit
[Music]
go
in the peace of christ
[Music]
now we will turn to
the virgin
you  know this statue of notre dame de
paris that we venerated and which
touched so many hearts and which have and which
allowed so many conversions it is there
on a chapel we cannot
go there right away  e now but
we can turn to her to
pray to her together we turn to
her singing that had written it
revised
[Music]
yes
I
that
go
[Music]
and back to the wall
m
the slap
[Applause]
oh
[  Music]
and
m
[Music]
and oh oh
notre dame de paris
pray for us
he